hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game a lot of you have uh
requested it's from chess.com super
chess league organized by hasanah in
chessbase india and it's a ding versus
viditz so really really a fine game you
guys are going to enjoy it let's dive
straight into it so ding with the white
pieces opens with d4 and you have to
shift into rapid mode because we're
covering the usgs championship which is
a classical tournament uh but these are
rapid games so uh keep that in mind and
also the the little robot in the corner
suggests this and also
if you're wondering about the title of
the video in the previous video i used a
bit of a bit of a violent title and it
seems that the youtube algorithm did not
enjoy it uh so the the outreach uh was
not very impressive so i'm trying a
different approach uh to try and make
the titles as gentle as possible so i'm
just i'm just checking if there's a
difference it's not you know becoming a
thing or anything uh so d4 by d we have
knight to f6 by visited bishop to f4 and
now d5 we have e3 and now striking in
the center with c5 so some sort of a
sort of an indian game not to the london
system as i i don't think it could be
classified as that would not without
knight to f3 so the captures on c5 queen
to a5 check we're gonna go after our
pawn here knight to c3 blocking uh and
now queen captures on c5 so we win back
our pawn and knight to b5 this has been
played many times going after knight to
c7 check we have to prevent this the
only good way to do it is knight stay
six we regarded the c7 square this way
and c3 now uh grabbing more space in the
center here we can develop the queen to
b3 to a4 but we are probably gonna play
for to add another defender to the
knight as bishop to d7 is played and now
a4 defending this knight with e6
preparing to develop the bishop here and
knight to f3 we have bishop to e7 and
now there is a game from 2010 and 10
between pia crumbling and eleanor frisk
where bishop to e5 was played but here
we have bishop to e2 by ding and it is
now as of move tender we have a
completely new game so let's see how
that it continues we have castles by
black castles by white and now queen
back to b6
uh freeing up the the c file for the
rooks but also freeing up the c5 square
for the bishop or the knight if needed
so queen to d4 offering a queen trade
and david avoids the queen trade with
bishop to c5 dean goes back queen to d3
and now rook f the c8 uh we have b4
saying okay this bishop will not last
here for a very long time the ship to e7
and now rook f to c1 and if anything
white is definitely controlling more
space here so black needs to figure out
how to how to unwind uh we have queen
back to d8 connecting the rooks uh we're
not connecting the rooks but um getting
the queen out of the way so we can uh
uh and uh the a7 pawn is a bit weak
because white can't attack it so it's uh
very interesting how black will take
care of this this is exactly what the
dean goes for he plays queen to d4 puts
pressure on the a7 pawn and now how do
you defend an interesting way would be
knight to e4 kind of saying okay if you
go for this pawn then maybe your c3 pawn
becomes a little bit weak uh but also
just a very nice square for the knight
but here vidi just goes back and defends
we have queen to b6 and now bishop to e5
here ding once if bishop captures the
queen captures bishop captures so the
bishop and knight are still attacking
the a7 pawn we have bishop back to e8
asking ding what is your
plan here ding plays h3 with h6 and now
uh ding says all right we're we're gonna
trade the queens now maybe a bishop to
d3 uh is a slight improvement and then
trading your queens but uh who who's to
say that so queen captures on b6 we have
eight captures on b6 and now bishop to
d4 going after the double b pawn and now
knight to d7
defending that b6 pawn we have bishop to
d3
and now f6 you can't really play on the
queen side the center uh for the moment
is well defended the bishop and knight
are controlling this so f6 definitely
makes sense we want to start pushing our
pawns here in the center uh we have e
forbidding and now e5 attacking the
bishop here we have bishop to e3 and now
it's a very very interesting position
there is one move that um
really makes the game come alive uh so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this uh well sort of objectively
best best move for black while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful pawn advancement and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's pawn to f5 that's the good stuff
because now you're asking white uh what
do you play here i'm just gonna capture
and there's nothing you can do about it
uh if you capture on f5 we just advance
the e4 pawn and we attack the bishop and
the knight here
doing nothing also isn't all that
impressive if you move one of the pieces
so it doesn't you know just get taken
then we can simply capture and then we
have this beautiful pawn mass in the
center uh we won upon life life is
really good for black here so instead
ding boldly accepted the challenge he
plays e captures on d5 he offers a piece
for two pawns and he has a beautiful
pass to d pawn so let's see how the game
continues with e4 of course you now have
to play this uh d6 attacking the bishop
here bishop to f6 and now bishop back to
e2 of course dean will save the bishop
so he puts it on this long diagonal we
have e captures on f3 grabbing the piece
now bishop captures and now rook a to ba
defending the b7 pawn and now
again it's a very very complicated
position a lot can be said about this
position black is up upon white is
definitely uh
you know controlling more space he's up
to pawns uh with a move like bishop to
d4 it's uh still anyone's game for
example if we trade here knight captures
there's no easy way for black to
activate the rooks and uh well this
knight just has no way of entering the
game it's uh well it's it's very very
complicated too complicated for a rapid
game one might say so instead of this
ding goes for a5 this will activate his
rook but it also gives black some very
interesting counter chances so here a
video played b captures on a5 rook
captures on a5 and now knight to e5
going after the bishop here so bishop d5
check and of course bishop to f7 uh we
want to trade down uh our bishops our
bishop on e8 wasn't really doing all
that much and the white's bishop is a
monster here so bishop captures with
czech king captures and even d7 bing
pulls out another one from his bag of
tricks and now of course if the pawn is
captured we can simply play this check
and pick up the rook on c8
video of course does not allow this he
plays a rook to d8 now uh attacks the
pawn twice and uh now what can thing
play here well he goes for the check
knight d6 check king to e6 and now he
captures another pawn eliminating the
defender of the knight here so rook
captures on b7 rook capture sunny a6
with check and now king to f7 you do not
want to touch the dark squares and allow
some sort of a check here could get very
ugly so here c4 ding has to give up the
pawn uh and he has to try and do
something he does have three past pawns
here but it's very hard to uh to push
them uh
you know
protectedly so rook captures on b4 and
now c5 hoping for that c6 push but of
course if it will not allow this he will
capture the d7 pawn we have c6 rook to
c7 and now rook to a7 trying to get rid
of this rook but luckily uh black can
defend it we have bishop to d8 uh and
now rook ceta a1 hoping to get a trade
here and then bring the other rook over
to a7 uh but king the e6 of course the
king will not remain on the seventh rank
we have rooked a8 going after the bishop
but now even knight captures on c6 and
now uh three pawns each on the king side
but the vidit is just up a full
piece so that's obviously winning for
black but it's a rapid game you still
have to play very precisely so rook to
c1 by ding bishop to f6 and now rook to
a6 uh attacking the knight twice so king
to d7 now rook to d1 check king the e8
and rook to c1 again going for that
knight hoping for maybe a nice
repetition here king d7 rook d1 check
but we have knight to b8 and this is a
beautiful
way to you know just minimize any
tension in the position now a rook trade
will happen definitely so rook to e6
with check king to d7 and now rook
captures and c7 with check we have king
captures on e6 uh but it doesn't really
matter even if you capture on c7 video
just played king captures on e6 and he
was in this position uh on move 47 that
dingler and resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the position is just uh completely
winning for black look at this three
points each on the king side one rook
each one bishop each but there's also
the knight for forbidden and of course
uh well it uh
it makes no sense uh playing such a game
where your opponent is just up a piece
without any sort of compensation
so really an interesting game and really
one that uh
well whenever you see a ding game he
will always go for that uh for that one
line that looks incredible that looks uh
uh you know superhuman that
completely wild where everything is
hanging such as this one here you know
the computer gives zero zero zero but of
course to us humans it is not a zero
zero zero and it wasn't uh it wasn't
easy finding a good way to continue here
in this position uh but uh you know it
definitely was playable so just this is
a really uh
a high level game even for a rapid time
format just the this beautiful f5
creating a past pawn like this and then
you know
uh video just out playing the ding from
a very very complicated position
uh but yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it thank you very much for
suggesting it uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to david tsurudi and
i would like to thank mr hoody guy tom
daralo you'll never walk alone and hb
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the us championship and this
event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day